Hey look who's here Anthony ku Mia it's
me hi buddy joylynn show me there was
another just another holdup it's
security but today's we've worked out
much faster that's definite and Don just
made a phone call it was okay they have
to get that into their system but I got
the Travis going on ago they're not
there's a problem secure they're not
letting about there that's why I got
quiet I was like I emailed Scott and
Andrew and panicking I'm like aids for
the security system okay I can't really
get rid of an end for women well I see
we're here we're on the right page so we
have 45 minutes last time 25 minutes
this time you're getting there
not even 25 this time this is about now
that wasn't bad at all surprised there's
cordial yeah the little getting assist I
can't panic and I texted Don oh really
yeah I'm like it's gone uh Edinburgh
yeah Eklund yeah thanks Ellie is easy
that's so funny what time is it there I
don't know but I'm later there I wrote
they're stopping ant at security we were
told it was okay he wrote checking I
said the fans know he's supposed to be
in security as [ __ ] us up again and
Don relax I'm making calls
spokesperson hurry they're letting a lot
Thank You Don all right yeah they were
130 over there you really overdoing it a
little bit yeah is he but he's he and uh
he's in Scotland for what Edinboro
because our our channel mate Colin or
what's a Craig Ferguson it over there
your channel they are channel mate Craig
Craig Ferguson six to eight on section
talk
Wow yeah he covers the the speaking
about factions evening we thought of
everything over and in the morning
what's going on in Edinboro I think it's
a comedy festival right every year it's
a massive festival really got hurt I'm
very honored you've been invited no I
can probably go if I wanted to but I've
never it's hard to get a month long you
do like shows where you have to go oh
you do like two weeks or a month in a
theatre and you just kind of do like a
run of shows there oh my god I would
just be like I got to go home you gotta
come to get answers I think I'd probably
get answered I get antsy if I'm anywhere
too long you know like give him
vacations cuz I got ride I'm [ __ ]
done get me out of here yeah why do you
guys just so harmless
well I like that it's because it's I
know it's coming back oh you know it's
yeah
is just strange people the train today
was getting me all I'm not like
agoraphobic or anything but I just don't
like people I don't like your basic
humanity I was really laughing at your
tweet this morning Anthony was on the
train and I just looking and he was
tweeting from the train and there was
some guy sitting in front of you that
was sketching he had a cell phone out so
he could see a photo and then he was
sketching what he saw on his phone and
Anthony wrote and I quote give it up you
saw I'm cleared it out because the
drains packed so I'm standing in the
aisle and I look I look over one of the
seeds and some guys there yeah and he's
got a rose
man he's got a rose on his phone and
he's got a sketch pad open and he's
sketching the rose I'm just like oh
[ __ ] stop it wasn't good
no it was terrible the proportions were
off the shading sucked he's probably
doing it he's probably doing it for
class oh yeah thanks zone for a class no
I didn't even think that like he's
getting his art homework done or
something well thank you again give up
just [ __ ] give up on that it's not
going to happen no hold on hold on rob
is interrupting the Anthony moments
first I got a sign terribly sorry when I
had to sign the visitor and eat they
that's from the front desk and the
making it he said that he has to sign it
they've never interrupted us for
somebody who has to sign that before all
right
really give your parents oh that's a
anything there we go oh I gotta sign it
though I'll do that
they've never arrived here if anybody
tips that for you okay
they've never cared before scribble the
name the bigger the fish yes young Rob
walking with a note public wiki asking
for a [ __ ] autograph I mean I would
actually yeah think about it but yes he
does that guy sketch us dunk that soft
in it like gee I take the train in
usually but it's a it's off-peak so I'm
not bothered by that many people but
this morning it's rush hour so all these
[ __ ] Long Island commuters on the
platform and they all know each other I
guess they're there
so it's like hi Betsy I wanted talking
to each other oh did you hear things
like they're doing like a one-person
show to one other person that's their
life of gossip did you hear the news and
then another one's talking about well
they want the wealthy to pay for the
subways here in New York in New York
City which I think it's great but you
know don't they take limousines in they
also [ __ ] they all come in with their
hot takes prepared yeah they give it to
the trash yes they almost know on the
way to the train station like what their
report repartee is going to be that
absolute were you annoyed when you heard
of us DeBlasio wanting to do that I
thought of you yesterday actually watch
them absolutely of course we're not
going to pass somebody's I doubt it yeah
but I listen these people they're like
oh they don't take the subway it's like
who's they a New York and you're making
like 200 grand
you're taking the [ __ ] subway yeah
but they consider that rich so this
woman is you know talking about dick
what do they take a limousine yeah we
hang out the top like big right that's
we do we sing song and if you're not
taking to somebody why should you pay
for it right it's kind of unfair I guess
they're thinking you know it's part of
the whole structure of the cinco system
so if you know you're wealthy and you're
up above you take care of the law and it
keeps the people down there I did keep
the Gantz back below ground I don't mind
that he keeping the scum below ground
feet that's come down there I just start
driving in the last straw because
there's been the same thing which
driving it was taking the training from
Westchester it was to peak time that's
just the best Chester that's right of
course
and like my wife dropped me off once and
the dog was barking out the window and
so some lady was I suburban senior right
yeah right and some lady goes like oh
the dog saying goodbye and I was like oh
yeah that not the dog said get the
peanut butter is John the third time the
third time that woman came up to me and
said oh so how's the dog as if we know
it's some kind of connection yeah I was
like I'm not I never taking the train
again I can't you can't everything you
do out in public turns into that the
Seinfeld kissing in the building episode
you know you give a little
a little something and then it becomes
obligatory yeah and then if you'd stop
doing it you're the [ __ ] [ __ ] what
was the episode about oh my god the
Kramer decided he wanted to put pictures
of everybody up in the lobby so with
their names under it so I might throw is
really dead and what happened in smooth
I blew it out like Saturday I was
singing I saw a video long I love why it
was fun wasn't from when you were
younger John Stewart it could have been
that we would like to discuss those
companies but my course go on with
science yeah well you know that everyone
would be friendly and they kiss each
other hello when they come in the
building it's like you know someone into
a and you're on 4b or something you know
you don't want that of course Jerry that
never wanted that
no sore tried to stop it and say look
you know I'm just not into the kit and
they got all [ __ ] pissed at him yeah
Thank You Lynette I knew it you know
this one Travis don't you I think I want
to maybe one or a huh yeah of course
I've never seen that one but now it's
really we tricked gym the other day oh
dude oh my god there was a good
Samaritan lawn and some people had gone
to jail for a year yeah I didn't know
that oh yeah the dick that happened in
real life so two Seinfeld
when Kesha goes up to him for a hug can
I have a hug yeah exactly
no no no no he didn't even know who she
was
know that like that Seinfeld that
Seinfeld famous yeah I just don't know
or care [ __ ] Kesha is know that was
and that's exactly how you know she
didn't give us she's like oh no just
real quick no yeah no he was so proud of
himself after that has his thing and
that's it he doesn't do anything he
doesn't want to do and should he have to
it no I'm - no no II just will not do
anything he doesn't want to do yes and
that's kind of uncomfortable for people
yeah yeah I guess it is when you're
around them but you know it's Jerry
you're going to do it is amazing how
many people like they they make money
they become powerful and they still have
this inherent desire to please oh you
don't even like Seinfeld is unique for
being the guy who's just unabashedly
not doing things he doesn't want to do I
respect that
yeah I do too but not like why wouldn't
you hug her it's so harmless to hug
somebody I didn't want to I didn't want
why would even want to like its to hug
somebody much hate hugging do you think
he's like thinking about websites and
[ __ ] that like Jerry and Kesha maybe I
decided he wants to touch someone he
doesn't know yeah yeah I think it's just
that thing he just was like I don't want
to hug you I don't know you know I don't
want to do it God he must be he must
never eat ass when he first meets a
person I wasn't that he never does
I remember Roland told me when he was me
met him la here's my ass I miss rating
system is pretty day when he met him
years ago I think he was with Judah and
he went to like some party and Jerry was
there Roland asked can we take a picture
and Jerry said yes so Roland goes to put
his hand around him like like his arm
around Jerry goes we don't know each
other well yeah we're gonna do that
Jerry do that he's just brutally yeah
and I love we don't know each other at
the cellar he was kind of he kind of
he's like we don't know he told about
the touch why but he still took the
picture man yeah I think I think he says
like his space being invaded or isn't
being touched I get that yeah you guys
that reputation for a while you know
people so Anthony hated being touched
yeah yeah cuz I just wouldn't want to
shake hands with some people some people
and it has like dirtier some people come
in it's just like a half [ __ ] man I'm
gonna do I'm gonna eat something I don't
have time to wash my hands and obviously
I would I would want to after shaking
yours so yeah as sometimes I was like at
I got a cold little fist bump what dice
used to do used where there's like
finger cut leather gloves I never
understood it if he was going to shake
his hand and he would just curl them up
in the balls they were shaking the bald
Columbus well he would shake hands of
somebody then go right he goes I got a
[ __ ] wash him again because he hated
people's dirty yeah yeah guys like that
and boss got me [ __ ] freaked out
about touching hands I never cared
really no I was like oh yeah this can't
gross you know the the [ __ ] subway
pulls those poles you got to hold on to
in the subway yeah because it's still an
archaic system with a jam on the brakes
would take the [ __ ] off you think they'd
be able to figure out where you could
just stand there do you watch any future
show you watch they're not all getting
jostled around lifted some [ __ ]
photon torpedoes going off as um they
got bad
choose and that yeah or something but it
may exactly every two seconds you got to
grab some grease it's so greased up you
know I did you see the video the guy
licking it we had that money food
there's a video the other day of a guy
licking look up guy does the most
disgusting thing in subway uh any
[ __ ] licks the pole
yeah that's that's [ __ ] terrible it
is do you try to find an area that's not
touched but you try to find like a weird
corner well your hand way up not a up or
I'm just holding it with two fingers but
you know whatever I hate even might even
be worse than the grease
it's just grabbing the pole and holding
it and it's warm
oh god yeah that's that and having to
use a public toilet warm toilet don't be
warm really seated slowly that I hate
that too you know somebody else's
[ __ ] he yeah I [ __ ] hate I get a
fast and when there's a line outside the
[ __ ] like anything worse than that
Sarah you might as well be rubbing cheek
so yeah really is disgusting you just
brought two but with a man open people
sit in a stall next that try something
crazy getting anything when I'm [ __ ]
why would they do that I like it quiet I
like a good quiet I don't like with
someone putting on a [ __ ] audio show
for me next to it all the disgusting
sounds coming out grunts and sure I'm
like as I've sat there sometimes just
waiting for everyone to leave the
bathroom so I could really you know let
go let go yeah loose you know there's no
music in the upstairs bathroom there's
music in this one there's none upstairs
that's why it makes it worse - [ __ ]
upstairs to the shooting music piping
through it really because the music
makes it a little bit easier right you
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's kind of private I'll
sometimes pretend I'm peeing in a urinal
and then liked a [ __ ] your pants take a
look
I just [ __ ] I pull my pants down to my
ankles I [ __ ] on the floor I've
pretended peeing in the urinal take a
long time take a long time washing my
hands and just wait for the room to
clear out and then just walk into the
stuff and go and yeah why don't you sit
in there and wait I don't even want
people I don't want any association with
people when I'm doing that do you know I
actually know a nation for it took me
maybe 25 minutes to shift I just
couldn't get it out did you push or did
you just wait I don't know like pushing
I
squirt of water up my [ __ ] Oh God
sometimes you commit you go in and you
might not be ready to finish up but you
commit yeah and you know it you've
loaded the torpedo into the torpedo tube
right and now it's Kali you got a fire
yeah yeah you're feeling it's in your
stomach I felt nauseous
oh here it is oh I'm gonna play it on
before I go ahead and play oh you're
dead what you doing you won't play it we
were setting you don't walk out of your
computer just oh they're terrible all
right I think that's funny
yeah hilarious first of all he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] cuz now someone else is
gonna grab that yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
if he wants [ __ ] diphtheria whatever
the hell you get off of that pole but
yeah other people have to touch I'm just
disgusted I it is pretty disgusting I'm
disgusted with like people in general
it'd be nice if you could just keep to
yourself right if a person could just
keep to themselves it's so wonderful
yeah if I'm just driving in my car it's
great what do you think the subway now
that you never did I never used to take
the subway I always take cabs but like
calves are just [ __ ] nuts during rush
hour you're not getting anywhere right
and now for some reason I don't know why
I get so queasy in vehicles when I'm not
charged I do too I get the cream my
tummy gets upset Oh guys yeah and uber I
love taking ubers but and it's been done
to death with the [ __ ] the talking
thing yeah like that there should be an
option that says you know I don't want
to [ __ ] up but you would think like just
pretend you're deaf if yeah yeah I do
but it's de f and I cross my arms like
that that's so cool boo I was terrible
he knows them all
besides oh yeah you get in there if I
want to initiate a conversation I'll do
it
it's not his decision to make right
whether I want to be talked to so I get
in there and one guy actually was like
because I wanted to to go like ah like
I'm in aa that kind of signals leave me
alone I'm riot and it goes tired
like yeah yeah and I hope that was it
then he goes how was your day
PSP how was your date like a [ __ ]
white you want to tell how your day was
oh did I ever
I was marvelous right until I got into
this [ __ ] bucket after you to drive me
home isn't infuriating when people don't
pick up on your one word and social
shoes yeah like fine how's your day fine
set so many people don't get it yet
yapping at you you put the headphones in
a lot of times that will do it you can
ignore them and they think you listen to
music oh yeah no I never took the
headphones and that helps a lot
yeah yeah well pretend you on the phone
call now is good pillow yeah all right
because they do that to me sometimes in
the cabs and stuff will you'll be
driving if you're like but there's
nobody like I'll excuse me not [ __ ]
you're talking to another Savage
I always do that even though I know
they're not talking to me it's so
annoying whatever I like you I'm like
excuse me I can't hear you I didn't know
like no no no no no oh you're doing that
thing that there was a law years ago
you're not supposed to do oh yeah I got
you yeah they just yeah but sometimes
they just yeah plowed I don't want a
little quiet talk sometimes there's
quite put it on speakerphone
I want nothing I want silence yeah gonna
roll the window down and get some cool
air in my face so I don't puke the way
that yeah I've yeah can't look at that
little screen they have down there and
you can't look at you're following
you're in their chart
I am I literally I have to leet laid
like my head back on the seat crack the
window so air flow then I'm like I'm
[ __ ] I'm like a fragile daffodil I've
always gotten carsick go it's over
really yes it sucks this is kind of a
new thing I could never read in a car
tell me what I can't read anywhere else
I'm an idiot it's one of those you know
motion with the eyes and the ear or
something yeah so I just get and then it
ruins you for like like an hour yeah
you're squeezing like [ __ ]
once you take a hansom cab like on the
bicycle oh yeah those guys don't like
themselves the worst aren't they he says
guys ah [ __ ] I'm traffic
[ __ ] up traffic and every time you try
to hail a real cab they'll pull over
like oh yeah yeah 57th Street I want to
go to the Comedy Cellar
Italy
ass [ __ ] a mile get out of here I
hate those guys - I didn't see it - come
and tell you at that Thursday I was
there Thursday who in later I wish I
would have known you were there yes we
had we had gone to see Artie Lange of
how our lines great good it's really
funny man and Russman Eve who I haven't
seen in a while and Brussels to add a
[ __ ] control yeah I love Russ yeah
funny and just really fun to hang out
with and who else is there Oh Grillo was
there from Stern Show
okay Steve Grillo a couple of girls you
know okay see and then he had a girl
with him and Russ is talking to some
chick I don't know what the hell's going
on okay yeah so we're just hanging out I
talked to Judah for a little while he
was there Dave Attell okay yeah is he
getting kind of some of the usual
suspects down there so uh I'm hanging
out at the bar and Jon Stewart comes in
and he goes downstairs and does a set
and I had to go to the bathroom at some
point you know the cellar you gotta
[ __ ] go downstairs
then you got to literally go between the
audience and the comic yeah go take a
piss
Trevor extracting room so [ __ ] like
so and I'm just trying to be as quiet
and invisible as possible you want you
said no but as I'm walking from the bat
the stairway to the bathroom which is
literally what three seconds I hear and
and I just did not I came in at just a
random spot in his act what in the
beginning when the end some in the
middle and I just hear just a bitter
disgusting old man with little hands
it's like okay obviously of course he's
doing his trump stuff I finish so you
walk in yeah I just knew where again
whatever you know that's his schtick
whatever I don't give a [ __ ]
so take the place I go back upstairs I
do love that you would criticize
somebody for spending time bashing a
president not you just had 48 years or
anything like that
absolutely I wouldn't have done it
that's ridiculous I I go upstairs back
to the bar and and the John comes back
up and he's got his
Tasi with him Aziz Ansari and like three
other beta [ __ ] males but he says no
pausing Oh comedians are just friends
not friends I guess I didn't recognize
them or anything
and Steve Grillo kind of was acquainted
with them through Stern's show or
something they go hey John how you doing
so Jon Stewart comes up and shakes
Grillo's hand and I'm standing right
next to rillo so I put my hand out like
hey Jon he goes I'm not shaking your
[ __ ] hand Wow here you are it's a
[ __ ] OH
I did your piece of [ __ ] yeah you said
I'm a piece of [ __ ] that's cool that he
knows who you are though yeah and what
you are guys really done is research
yeah so I know my body of work I was
like what the fight all of a sudden I
turned is big holy hey bud what's your
the NAM I was like I was like what's
your [ __ ] problem and he goes I know
you [ __ ] you you talk [ __ ] about me
so I start laughing I'm like how how
long have you been in this business you
new to it are you kind of nude doing a
show and having people [ __ ] on you is
that is that it yeah yeah make that nice
it was I was going to go with jerks tour
I actually should have I should have
gone with jerks books uh no and then
he's uh he's call me piece of [ __ ] again
he said a piece [ __ ] I wouldn't shake
your hand if you paid me I think gorilla
yelled up something like that figures
you're [ __ ] phony Hollywood piece of
[ __ ] graduate I don't yeah girl I was
jealous because I am that girl that just
thought why I asked him to cuz girl had
my back oh god it was kind of nice good
it's kind of nice so uh I said I I go
what yeah I talk [ __ ] about you on my
show and stuff I I said that's kind of
what I do because also - so you come to
my face and now you tell me it's fake I
was like no except it's not fake is that
I respect what you do and that the fact
that you carried a show for as long as
you did
I think your political ideology [ __ ]
stinks and that's what I that's what I
talk about
I got our know you from a hole in the
wall what the [ __ ] you know what am I
saying about you and then no what's his
name the owner of the cellar
no no no come up and I was like hey hey
guys hey
was it hostile like was it was it a 10
yes it was very tense a lot of cursing a
lot of yeah yeah [ __ ] you and and there
was right yeah he has come to come to
blows well that I think that's why Nome
came over and he's like all right guys
all right guys and I'm like I'm like
we're talked weird else we're talking
here right I'm not gonna like I'm not
going to hit anybody
don't [ __ ] yeah right tents or
anything and I just don't like then I
look around for seconds like on a Judah
is kind of like crying in the corner and
it's just everyone's looking and I
didn't realize it was becoming a
spectacle right of a thing yeah yeah
well it happens yeah they broke it up
though after then no no no one kind of
went off a little bit kind of went away
and let us just kind of sort it out and
after a couple of [ __ ] yous and and and
things Jon Stewart actually went he goes
I look yeah I probably shouldn't have
just gone off like that you know all
right all right
and I you put his hand out and shook his
hand eh that was it
I kind of go back to the the bar and he
went to his table of [ __ ] women men
after diary
whoever wanted you it would be funny
when he put his hand he put hand if you
refuse to shake something was not even
good ice shaking your [ __ ] back at
that [ __ ] live hand out of my face
exactly well had you guys had him on
years ago yeah we had him on a long time
ago yeah it was well before
sure but daily show I think he was doing
that other he had a show before the
daytime TV with Howard feller yeah
that's right I did that show Oh Divya I
remember I don Jamison I first went Don
James me work for MTV and me and
Florence we were extras in a sketch on
the Jon Stewart Show probably 1994 93 I
remember what we did it was not good not
a good sketch it wasn't good no you're
shaking a soda machine or something
who
so think of a solar machine now but it
was a baby it's psychological were you
uh were you like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was
that are you like oh that's kind of cool
again into a fight with John Stewart no
I was kind of like [ __ ] this guy yeah
like like a little angry yeah about the
whole thing that it even happened but
can you kind of attacked you as a as a
person yeah yeah he was like [ __ ] not
like oh I don't agree with what you say
[ __ ] Bryan you olofi tell you had
attacked him and he's just going I'm
gonna shake your hand you attack me
that's kind of what you'd want to do if
someone had attacked you I don't know
you hate his politic but he never bashed
you but you're - so you ain't easy fight
to get personally did he never bash me I
don't think so fired or anything
I don't think so knows who knows I don't
know all I'm thinking is it's a you know
a show he does his show oh it's fake so
every time he hears a trump say
something everyone looks at him and he
makes that dumb mug face into the camera
he does that in real life everything's
real yeah it's all kind of children it
was kind of really silly but yeah having
him it was it was what it was it was
kind of aspect it made radar on lives
right now radar Online had gotten like
nothing right and then they were did
something where it was like Anthony's
girlfriend held him back it was like uh
but they made it sound like Steve
guerilla was my girl and Anthony's
girlfriend just Steve yeah judging uh
does radar online post a lot of like
stern stories when already goes off
right yeah yeah I feel like Steve Grillo
probably just tips them off on
everything you think it's Steve huh yeah
I mean doesn't that make complete sense
could be an epic swearing match at New
York Comedy Club why they have video of
John Stewart chatting with fans before
Letterman I know what he is
yeah quick click just click this and
they posted a great picture uh-oh there
it is go go - yeah right there where it
says a chromia being held back by his
girlfriend and former houses
that means the right girl baby works for
Howard and he's dated you know they
think that there's no comma before and
but there are times where you might want
to put it to clarify Mike backed by his
girlfriend and for you know he or former
Howard Stern alum Steve Carillo and by
his girlfriend something so there's some
more words and you must make a
distinction between girlfriend and
former Howard alum yeah I was ready to
be a comma before you know what if okay
he's technically correct but if that was
saying that he was your girlfriend did
be a comma after all um it would say
Clooney is being held back by his
girlfriend and former Howard Stern alum
Steve Brill oh oh right cuz it's a title
right there's no comma before that so
that means that it's a separate incident
or how about person who Mia being held
back by his girlfriend it right you know
something like that I just but I kind of
think it's funny that did your
girlfriend hold you back no that was
another thing that just never happened
were talking about Steve yes okay the
girlfriend see didn't you read it yeah I
think that's the bigger story radar
Online needs to report that Anthony Kumi
is dating Steve Grimm right although Wow
getting the lowdown radio industry love
did you call him a [ __ ] phony
Hollywood [ __ ] maybe it was Steve
yeah Steve guerrilla yelled yeah
how would you argue for that says that
you yelled back yeah I don't they didn't
get anything right five minutes they
really nah wasn't even that long ok it
was probably three minutes together is
kind of yelling you get a picture no I
should have read me that well yeah yeah
yeah smile and it was like no go back at
it no [ __ ] funny that he knew you were
talking [ __ ] though I use people people
no no people always know yeah yeah yeah
when they talk you know I'm sure he
would never have come I go I hear you've
been very complimentary of me right like
even if I was but when people talk [ __ ]
about you you [ __ ] know you know yeah
and you probably you play some of that
he thinks it's fun
funny and he's to probably go this guy
hates me now like years ago yeah I
haven't even talked about John Stehr I
made fun of his crying when the trade
center [ __ ] got hit I mean cuz he
well a lot of people are upset about
yeah I don't try it I notice I know
Antoine Kamiya was probably celebrating
but but a lot of people were actually a
set of my hunters and what I'm saying my
friend is that it was after when he went
on the show and said how the Trade
Center used to be his view out his
window and now you know it's gone but
but now he can see the Statue of Liberty
like the buildings were gone and that
and he started getting a little choked
up about that on the show and I'm like
but then then he becomes a proponent of
[ __ ] terrorists what I'm just now
he's a full message of the show my day
yeah well no I'm talking years later
he's one of those people that after you
know never forget he's Pro I thought of
course he's Pro lies and pretty much
that I didn't watch the later seasons
yeah I must have missed that 2005 yeah
yeah yeah I guess I fell off a little
bit it's just one of those that will
blurt out Islamophobic and [ __ ] to
anybody that's saying anything about
Islam so you know Bill Maher has called
Islamophobic just as a mate he's not
100% on board with Ben Affleck called
him that yeah and I'll just leave omen
owner families right what did he want
that edited out by the way--by I
remember that yes that's true yeah yeah
that's absolutely true it's one of those
it was a it was a TV show on a public
television right probably would never
have gotten seen anyway unless it had
this big thing and a celebrities would
have their background looked up their
ancestry looked up but it was supposed
to be interesting and then Ben Affleck
was one of the guys of the guy looked up
his ancestry and found speckly with the
slave oh yeah why would I embarrass you
it's not you because it's [ __ ] PC
[ __ ] Olly was you Anu is a yeah my
family
you should embrace that like hey I'm not
who my family was or whatever doesn't
matter it doesn't even matter and you
heard it there HBO probably you've heard
it yes whatever this guy give Anthony's
I know the show fabulous I forgot yeah
you tend to know everything yeah I like
dicks
I know what you're going to say about
I'm sure you yeah that HBO's so there's
the show that's supposedly only miss
Pratt knows no not that same Crone's no
Game of Thrones bedside mini rupture I
like dick so has gone out oh yeah you
good okay see there's a show that's in
development scripts has not even been
written yet but the concept for the show
that HBO I think has picked up the two
guys from Game of Thrones
yeah which guys the guys are created
it's all about the actors no okay but
did the concept it's it's like man in a
high tower which is that concept for
that show on Amazon is what if the
Germans in Japan won World War two Jesus
Nazi and bah-bah-bah under even one of
that would be doing well um but this
show is what if what if the South had
won reacts not one had successfully
seceded okay so like it's not like the
South has control over America it's just
the north is still the north but in the
South it's current day and slavery is
still happening and it's everything that
they wanted to maintain and people are
already without a script without
anything gel not everyone just like
everyone isn't mad no not a people yeah
there are people who are angry there are
some people that are angry about this
all those creative or protest again I
think it's ludicrous to just say well is
ludicrous mad no I think it's ludicrous
to get angry at things like this like
Anna can show you how good it is that
they didn't secede this is why these
[ __ ] this is why this is where
liberals really do stink and you guys
got to stop it you're like biting
yourself in the ass all the time it was
like you're the ones that push this
[ __ ] don't talk about that don't say
this don't don't make fun of that now
there's an actual legitimate creative
work being made and they're gonna have
trouble getting this made because people
are protesting the concept of it but you
hear about another show though I was
going to say Anthony whom you described
the show as a laugh riot which I am yeah
there hasn't even inscription it doesn't
make sense but but there's outrage at
that yet there's zero out rave at
another show that's going to come out
with a similar kind of
a plotline just wants Amazon is it
Amazon doing the fun maybe could be
wrong anyway
the civil wars over the south is given
to the former slaves they give them the
South as their own country and blacks
are now running the south after like a
hundred and ten years of kind of this
cold war almost between the the North
Shore now and the south United States it
turns out the south becomes this
industrial juggernaut doing very well in
the world and the north with the white
people in it
it's just floundering and failing crime
now needs help from the cell with the
the black america and i where where's
the outrage if that revision is kind of
history that's what the show is called
is it black america black I'm not I'm
not joking up is it called black America
yes I just turn on the news and I see
that show III don't know my corners I
don't mind those shows because they're
design flooring options I just love it
but you're getting mad at one and not
mad at the other say it's all we know
it's revisionist history that's what
it's supposed to be it's nice to be boys
it's fiction yes of complete partner
fiction fiction Shh it's a dramatized
dramatized eyes eyes series of events
yeah well remember when that man in the
high tower came out yeah and people were
a little flustered because someone in
their inevitable wisdom thought to
decorate up some of the subway trains ah
like they were injured yeah during
[ __ ] 30 really bad idea all was that
ah yeah you have to be delicate you have
to be a little bit like not like eBay
could for promotion turn their website
into a slave auction that meant to
promote the HBO show you can't do that
you probably wouldn't want to do that
that doesn't make any sense
didn't they they did against Seinfeld
they did a Seinfeld thing on the trains
where certain trains would decorate it
up with like a Seinfeld motif and that's
good but you can't take a show about no
Nazi Germany winning the war and then
make the train car look like a Nazi
today car just doesn't it doesn't work
that the only thing that's annoying is
when they try to do it with a
politically uh with a message like I
like if they
like this is what we think would have
happened that's everything those that
only the message everything is a message
and everything it should turn off face
now I'll just watch an alien covenant I
didn't Italian we got the one where the
alien is they think it's going to be a
nice alien but it's not it's not very
nice at all and it's very scared is it
attack everybody on the ship it attacks
everybody it tries to hurt them and it
didn't learn
it's terrible no it was that I said it
was good in that it wasn't [ __ ] like I
like this because it wasn't total [ __ ]
yes because Prometheus Tonkin the other
ones I liked the four original ones
three was my least favorite out of the
original four but the other ones are
really good I don't remember that
honored the third one was one in the
prison with uh what the [ __ ] his name
Kurt Russell and Celeste it's a lot oh
that was a funny one thing that was it
know what Angeles oh god that was not
turkey roaster in who'd stuck in my
heart not not turkey roaster that was
Pacino and De Niro and rooster oh yeah
cold a Cobra no Co bretty was cold
Marion cab ready
Marion coab ready how did that sting I
was terrible they shook a match oh he's
secure
Oh oh shoot oh my table careful why
talented so aliens race yeah alia the
the Covenant alien coven look large is
the fifth one they end up that does
actress it wasn't too bad but it's
supposed to be a prequel to alien like
Prometheus was was we have two
Prometheus but before alien the first
one that we always trim about the front
the first first one
yeah that's supposed to be the first one
in order but the first one was alien
they did a prequel and then now yeah so
uh I'm looking and the crew of the
Covenant which is the ship the crew is
like can we have one couple of just
straight white dude and a straight white
woman no no I think it was one everyone
else was black chick white dude that's
cool black dude white chick that's cool
and then at some point a guy dies and
and another guy like goes to kiss them
on the lips
and you see his wedding ring it's like
they're gay couple it's a dressed-up
[ __ ] is going on exactly it's every
website you click on Anthony's mad
because he got tricked into being
emotionally invested in gays those
Apaches were in it yeah yeah didn't tell
me they were kidding you know I just I
can't stand that they're putting this
2017 sensibility Thursday's though into
a movie no here's my point though uh-huh
like that was their crew now you go to
alien which is supposed to take place
after this mm-hmm and you don't see
[ __ ] Dallas trying to set the black
guys cake on the [ __ ] Nostromo not in
well knocking on the bonus PJ's Adam
yeah this director's cut yeah they're
making these movies though they're
probably trying to say okay how can we
represent like you can't undo the
original Star Wars [ __ ] those shitty
whom those say those little figures have
popped up it was really terrible
what's ours no no the men when they were
talking like it was like a 3d oh yeah
yeah
you mean leave me saying that like now
we know that the future technology would
be so much better yes and then on but
they still have to make the hologram
staticky because we liked that right and
also I already there but the problem is
now that we see that this is where all
these couples are going they have to
represent can now you look stupid if you
don't represent the future like the way
it's going it doesn't look stupid in the
70s because no one saw that coming I
don't think the future is calling there
I think this is the thing they shove it
down our throats I live in New York New
York I wear I work in New York City I
walk the streets around I see what's
going on out there I'm not constantly
turning around and seeing the amount of
same-sex couples and interracial couples
that I see in television commercials
every friggin minute it's all it's not
even the ones that you would understand
like all right there's a jacked black
dude with a white chick or something or
a white dude or the model look in black
chicken stuff but it
they show these commercials it's a 65
year old white guy with a black woman
having cereal in the morning think where
does that happen
yeah that's what's getting angry about
it
you think that might be the underlying
issue here that did in 2017 be mad at
interracial couples they mad you why
don't you say I'm on to them when I want
it I'm on to the whole when is not the
couples what's the agenda that's being
pushed the agenda that's being pushed is
an indoctrination of just let's let's uh
have diversity for for everything for no
other reason than diversity but it's all
is it like do you think we probably
should be okay with people having
relationships with people they're of
different races I think it's absolutely
grand your issue more that it's all
interracial couples and no white and
white couple thank you you don't like
the agenda behind the idea of the agenda
as opposed to interracial couples don't
you know about but it's the idea of the
agenda being fortune agenda being for
that is that everything should be this
and a straight white dude and a straight
white woman is like the worst thing that
could happen I noticed that I just saw
something the other day it was a good
help a way to help stop global warming
stop having children right and it was
the cover of a magazine or a website and
it showed three white little white the
whitest little babies you could say it's
like here's an article preaching don't
have kids and they show three little
white if they put three children of
color on there there would be outraged
because you know so these people are
supposed to not have kids that's all I'm
saying there's so many white babies know
what there's tons of white babies that's
right there's a ton of white babies I
just had one there's all of you alleged
are you say I just had one in air-quote
half white justice half Travis all
you're gonna say going on is the same
thing completely different movie the
latest of the live-action Beauty and the
Beast at the end of the movie when they
all turn back into humans - boiler bugs
me it was all interracial couples
that's dope don't happen and it's and
it's something it's so obviously noted
right that's what it is so it becomes so
obvious you're like all I see what
you're doing here Walt is doing 8000 rpm
and it says what do you think that white
frozen he didn't like that don't you
think the white heteros kind of had
their run though like they'd be a hell
of a run I mean we watch me say which
one no no but I guess I get your point
it's it's it's everything but yeah I
think that's what it is everything but
it's like it just like being
heteronormative whatever you want to
call it being normal they are such a bad
they over represented yeah it Holly why
do they try to over represent it because
they're trying just to show that but
it's it's annoying
buzzing uh who cares like I know what I
know it's like this girl trying to force
their ideology and tie like I already
think it's fine but they're a bunch of
dopes that actually pick up on it and
become I just read something this
morning about a [ __ ] camp at six years
old
yes ivory Scott yeah Jim you're gonna
love this Jimmy's school for yeah
there's a nice elated Caribbean village
where it says it says oh my god yes
genetic disorder causes little girls to
turn into boys and grow penises when
they hit puberty what's the what's a
disorder called good girl lightest so
it's as a girls in an isolated Caribbean
village became male become male and grow
penises when they hit puberty due to a
rare genetic disorder it's estimated
that one in ninety tilled Rijn born in
Solio this there's a lack of enzyme by
the way this explains hot dog - at sea
Kathy's Dominican it is estimated that
one in 90 told Rijn born in Salinas in
the Dominican Republic make the
transition by the time they reach 12 it
is so prevalent that it is no longer
considered abnormal and the children are
simply referred to as the guava doses
which means wonderful with the eggs are
good
which literally translates to penis at
12:00 some name sounds like a news to
you yeah and more with penis as well
yeah that's a weird one because it's
supposed to happen in the womb but
because the lack of enzyme and the
testosterone kicks in then it happens in
there too it's a really very very rare
thing yeah but does show you that
there's all this weird [ __ ] with gender
that we don't understand yeah there's
some weird [ __ ] in all but I I think
there's a tomb and I understand I've
seen some some stories where they got
some kidney seven years old and it's
like oh I want to be a girl or I'm gonna
be a girl and you say like oh yeah you
can see that that's fine whatever yeah
whatever you want to do you know but I
honestly think there's some parents out
there now that are using it like a
munchausen syndrome by proxy thing or
instead of making the kids sick they're
just going to change the gender so that
all the attention could be on them going
look at my gender fluid child
yeah that's although we won't allow we
won't allow anybody to refer to our
child as having a gender until the child
is ready as well by design nouns right
they'll let us know gender fluid my
favorite beverage we correct anybody who
uses the wrong pronoun a boy
yeah our child is referred to it today
okay good for you good for you it gets
out of whack like it gets to the point
where you're like and this is where the
if you just kind of did it a little bit
like just yeah to wear it if you
represent it accurately right people
would have less of an issue with it than
it being forced like then you're a
criminal if you don't see everything
either I would exactly know like they
okay don't you think because it wasn't
portrayed accurately before I mean I do
is overly white now you got to make up
for it so before you can do it angler in
blue know I think it's a reflection on
just the society and what a guy years
ago you look at the percentages of race
in the United States it was represented
you'd think that race was accurately
represented yeah
back in the day yeah when you know you
get you get places where it's 80% white
they don't give a [ __ ] if anything else
is on TV but white people
you know yeah so then are you excited
for the Roseanne reboot where they're
going to have a nine-year-old
gender-fluid gender-fluid kissy are they
named at nine I don't know I don't know
if they're wrong to do that does Kevin
you want people to watch the show
and you're trying to get younger people
to watch the show no but I'm saying you
want younger people to watch the show
yeah and in order to resonate with them
it's like you have to or they're going
to look at it like it's archaic sounds
like their target demo is nine year old
no not nine year olds but a liberal who
are in their 20s will go okay I've seen
families like that it's almost like when
I would watch Dick Van Dyke or shows it
I didn't feel like I didn't connect to
them it didn't represent anything I know
right I like stuff from the 70s when I
grew up stuff little bit but the goofy
that looks now and they try to shoehorn
in something that was relevant of that
time and then it becomes I think this I
think these these years we've been
living in of late are going to date very
poorly I think it we're looking back
it's going to look very silly in history
unless we're evolving and yeah we never
you I think you think the progress is
going to be looked at like Genco jeans
yes I'll gently for that [ __ ] yeah
they're cool now they are going out
right did my jegos come in yet
no not yet okay well let me know indeed
there was a photo on Twitter going
around over the weekend what was the
Travis go it was hot or under shelter
jeans you interrupted it's an old photo
Hulk Hogan and Jen coach oh yeah well no
it's one of my favorite hole calls I'm
sorry tango and cash by the way oh dang
going to thank you to the listener it's
like the most late 90s early 2000s photo
ever it's just Hulk Hogan in these wide
black
Jenko jeans there it is that's before is
that my gosh it was pretty looking at
dwarfed that is he looks like a dwarf
that man is six foot ten Wow thanks for
the 90s it's right well this probably
looks looks like the the early late 90s
early 2000 where they they're probably
comfortable pants though I love dice
loose particles were the best you like
having your [ __ ] just kind of hang in
there would you like me in a pair of
Jenko 's yeah
and finally be like we have a young hip
Co yeah hello Kay hello fellow kids okay
look at how cool that guy like I
probably got [ __ ] all the time that
yeah like the hole in the back of his
pantry lies manly look go what do you
think of a of Chelsea Handler did you
hear what she said
of course I did I figured that you'd
agree with her in that one yeah Chelsea
Handler said that she said that she made
it her idea of a joke was wouldn't it be
funny if all people who thought racism
was funny had to go to jail right she
says there was guys were arrested for
doing a Nazi salute and she was wouldn't
it be funny if we had laws that made
racism illegal or something like that or
yeah that would it be great would it be
great if yeah if people who thought
racism was funny had to go to jail okay
like that yeah people had great response
so no I was no treat was it no our tweet
was uh
yeah what would be great would it be
nice to have laws here for people who
think racism is funny it's funny yeah
yeah and the guys got arrested and it
was like being yeah and Shelley's funny
and say what are you doing like you
can't if you make jokes a certain way
and then kind of come out and go hey you
shouldn't go out to make those jokes
people started finding all her all her
racially motivated joke yeah all of our
jokes yes all of a sudden she's miss
hypocrite she's and then other people
are saying things like peg good idea
Sarah Silverman would be in jail then
for some of the Yahoo that she she has
said so it Richard Pryor yeah exactly I
know ray says I would Chelsea Handler
but you know Martin would be Jim do I
never thought racism not joking matter
yeah that's good you remember that is
good good now but I'm not going to you
know occasionally we slip up and put a
tweet out there that we might wish we
could pull back in some for example go
um I don't really have it conceptually
you're saying yeah yeah yeah
twitter has become this thing where
everyone thinks every single tweet is a
hundred percent and it's perfect and
it's you and it's everything you have
every thought never maybe she had a dumb
thought maybe she'll she's got caught up
in a moment and well yeah this should be
illegal and not thinking of the overall
picture like yeah I've done it like a
dumb thought you
send out right we forget sometimes that
we are just sending out thoughts on
Twitter and that was a stupid thought
that she sent down right sometimes
tweets are official statements from the
President of the United States of
America that's the difference between
the president making policy statements
and people just kind of throwing out
thoughts but even some part I just
thought yeah is there a difference there
is you know I mean it should be what I
think you should be more careful yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that there's a
huge difference but uh he should be more
careful
but yeah sweets shouldn't be taken that
seriously but if it's that that's what I
wish that Donald Trump had been like hey
it's just my Twitter like I'm just a guy
with a Twitter I happen to be the
president we all realized that yeah but
then he said these are official
statements well that that was also just
thrown out there that is an official
statement that's just an idea you're
right
we're now incepting Donald ProStreet
yeah exactly we should yeah I we're just
we're acting like that there they're a
complete work of who you are as a person
they're not they're not well thought out
a lot of guys are just a thought
yeah you just throw it out there and it
should be taken in that context but man
it is law now yes law I think I'll tweet
this yes do that
I'm kind of stunned but not surprised at
that Google guy a Google guy got fired
together he put out manifesto there call
yeah I read about women of Pete Clara in
the workplace over at Google and and how
they don't make good engineers they
don't make good coders they don't make
good things that he's doing the gender
difference he did and it was looked at
like oh okay this guy's just speaking
his mind his opinion and he should be
fine and I was loved laughing at this I
was fired fired so fired
oh yeah and now he's been fired well you
can't I mean you can't watch put out an
article if you're like working for
Google and be like yeah women are bad at
math I can't you do that because then
women are like hey that's mean we're not
bad at math yeah but he believes and
and through his experience of working he
actually has experience he does what
he's saying that he doesn't believe
women can do as well as men in general
so he writes about it and gets fired
that's ludicrous again ludicrous coming
up later it's insane that you can't yeah
voice your opinions we in a very
articulate manner just if they're not
popular with certain groups yeah yeah
the only reason he got fired is that
it's not the popular thing if he wrote a
thing on how great diversity is and how
great having women in the workplace and
it was still German he wouldn't have
been fired
there wasn't a good and they didn't
agree with their policies so he gets
fired that's [ __ ] scary you should
allow those III those uh what I think
Bill Maher had a great quote he goes the
best disinfectant is light I think which
means that if people let let the light
shine on the idea and if people don't it
doesn't take people see it's a bad idea
so should just stay woke um yeah I don't
know I don't disagree that you do how
about you write an article that points
out how [ __ ] bad his article is what
will you write like there you go I write
article about a prostitutes one totally
my first time article and it was one
that I look back on there's a couple
things I should have phrased better than
that but a woman who came out and wrote
an article that's like she said I was I
was terrible I actually bumped into her
once again I was too harsh on you but uh
like like she didn't agree with it
yeah so that's what happened to me I
wrote something somebody wrote something
what they didn't like it and I treated
both of them yeah that's what you do
that's what you do you don't have to
like it you can no I was wrong fine a
woman that works at Google could guy
grow something up I can write something
up and make them look like a complete
buffoon ye wrote that should be the
consequence once you start firing people
for stuff like this and I hear it all
the time I say well it's definitely you
know it's kind of casting a shadow on
the freedom of speech no a company could
do whatever they want yeah I get that
part of it that's free don't worry about
it but you don't understand the
implications for of a company when they
start telling people what they can and
can't relate to their code
workers as far as their ideas go that is
some [ __ ] Orwellian [ __ ] right there
you know there's a chess player named
Nigel short he's a grandmaster I just
beat him but oh do you really Qi do you
know them
how'd you do [ __ ] checkmate [ __ ] yeah
checkmate so I looked at scarlet
Johannesburg hey that's my mate I'll
check you out oh my god I can't wait
till later yeah yeah tips a pinch all
right she pycnogenal sure was saying
that that when just aren't as strong as
chess players as Meg now I get maybe
there's different reasons for that too
and some woman said is it possible
because they get the messages that
they're not as good at certain things
they don't pursue by direct argument but
not as many women play chess do they
separate chess by men and women they do
a male and a female category well then
if the people who organized it if
they're saying that that's not true it's
not fair what he said then I would say
well then why are you separated they
shouldn't one they're not a physical
thing it is no that should be something
that is absolutely hi everyone hi grant
it would show a disparity I believe it
may yeah but I mean eventually I think
if it was one one one group I think to
be more women playing what's our call
but don't you think there's a difference
between men and women in in the mind
also yeah in how they handle certain
situations the emotional aspects of
things logic reasoning all that stuff
that's hardwired in that it's it's just
part of being that gender maybe so but
people don't want to believe that they
want to think we're all exactly the same
we all have the same exact capabilities
and and we could all do everything that
everyone else can do and it's [ __ ]
yeah it's okay to be better at it
because there are things that maybe
women are better at like then women are
probably better at relaying oh yeah yeah
when they are better at certain sugar
like I don't know the chess argument I
mean it's there's plenty of female chess
grandmasters but yeah there's up this
top yeah I think that there's more of
the differential within people in
general than just segwaying it off
between men and women because a lot of I
go on most women are better at
me yeah better than me at sport really
yeah most women would beat me at almost
quadriplegic at sport and things like
that like there's not yeah
the hardline rules don't really well
you're looking at an extreme example
here somebody that's really just not
physically yeah you're a really you're a
little bit you're worthy I'm not that
that's well you know you're looking at
that end of the business I think you
guys just said micro instead of macro
you didn't have to go closer out making
a true bethe [ __ ] [ __ ] right what are
you talking about BC B yeah being a half
we should you should break up friend
down to low what are you good Rock um my
[ __ ] is heart Oh God are you gonna break
their own art than me babe you book my
heart to [ __ ] put it together Jesus
[ __ ] a lot of songs about heart yeah
yeah yeah no they very same tone as
yellow I'll make love to you with maja
and also no I make love to you with my
heart as well as my pecker oh that was
so swear that's cool forgot with the
yeah I can line later that's great
alright we can that we take a break I
should play that maybe play the jingle
for ant I have yardage it's a good point
why not yeah we can come back with the
jingle people always get very confused
because I think at the beginning of the
show again but it won't be it'll be the
middle of the show but we'll play the
jingle anyway and you can get tickets to
the live Sam Roberts wrestling podcast
as a Highline Ballroom it's a Wednesday
August 14th it's a week from tomorrow so
go get tickets right now Dan Soder is
going to be there and other surprise
guests it can be very very fun Highline
Ballroom calm sounds fun yeah I don't
have anything bladed promote other than
Sam's wrestling podcast I don't have any
gigs till the end of September which I
will announce to oh I think I'm going on
sale Friday might be the Talking Stick
resort casino I'm going back there that
was an amazing gig I just don't remember
I should part well Kings - gasps I call
my penis deleting sticky so softly
Kingston sauce okay
tepid my erections are tepid and you're
promoting the Anthony commune Network oh
yeah not how media come right once your
big announcement the other big innocent
do twenty first guys cool we're taking a
big announcement wonder when it should
be wonder yeah yeah yeah well what yeah
you do it on the scheduled day yeah
that's how you do these things
everyone's not amazing and announcements
keeping secrets right right or for me
clearly worry about it I think it's that
I look at my whole life
and I I see the awful terrible things in
my life and turn it into something funny
it's time to start the show the gang is
ready let's go come on yeah we're back
yes eylem our number two is the asylum
oh yeah welcome visit so we're getting
crazy haha look at ya checked himself
into the asylum Wow Anthony Korea like
the inmates are running the asylum a
that's not true no not at all what's not
true no no we're late another nights we
run what we run yourself that's it that
make no sense yeah let's just try to
jump in not doesn't work that way don't
call this inmate we don't want that oh
yeah hashtag what's the Hasnain you be
committed that's a be committed hashtag
be committed to the asylum book that
letter that's gonna go ahead and work
for you a couple ways if you think oh
you know like that no oh right like I
don't get it be committed Oh cuz you're
committing right be committed to the
show all sure you're gonna want to
listen to each and every morning that
each and every one and every more like
canker sore hurts
did you get a canker cover this morning
I didn't know this morning oh my god you
need
take your cover it's going to come back
what the [ __ ] is a canker cover Sam's
hat ha ha ha ha you're a canker that
means Jim has got sores in his mouth not
a canker sore oh geez and so yesterday
he came in with a canker cover a bandage
over it put it in your mouth and I did
too it did knock most of it out but it's
just a little tender - where are they
only one where is it's right under this
plush point for my mouth guard scraping
oh I'm sure that's what it's from yeah
yeah really no sign an STD no of course
not you don't want that out there not
like Usher
[Laughter]
well he gives you to the gigantic woman
that said it you like the big girl yeah
that's the most embarrassing part I've
come pick I believe that I sure likes a
big girl you think is so I I would think
so I know it's great is a black twitter
has been all over this yes they started
putting all kinds of videos out of him
getting big girls to dance on stage with
them so there's all this evidence of
Usher love and big girls yeah Wow yeah
he likes big girls but the thing is
which is weird because he dated the the
skinny one from TLC uh chili that was
probably just like for optics you know
nice little look I see you don't want to
be seen with a [ __ ] or only the big would
it be real see they're like all know
that she's giant and a giant woman she
laughing here's the problem James this
woman gets on TV and all over social
media right yeah and she goes she's
suing Usher he didn't give her herpes
right but he had it she said so she's
suing him because she cares for her
health
and she's a vegan ah yes you're SIA and
you know what brontosaurus well I was
gonna say she's a big girl
that statement open her up to quite a
few jokes about her weight I bet yeah
yeah you can't how can you say that
would be like you know somebody sneezed
on the subway right and then
you sue them because you got a cold
without any proof that that they gave
you the whole yeah she has no she has no
case no it would be like if somebody who
had a cold sneeze on the subway and you
didn't get a cold right you were like I
could have got a cold
yes I wouldn't have or if you kiss
someone radical I wouldn't have kissed a
person then your day to Colton right
like it's just she's got no case she's
just trying I mean she'd put on Facebook
like before she needed money right and
stuff like that like I'm trying to get
paid she's trying to get her bag
catch her bag that's right I don't know
that term it's called-- what does having
to get her bag like a bag full of money
I was house that means another one yeah
Khalid oh yeah I didn't know that - uh
is it confirmed that did he say I don't
I don't have no appeaser
I don't think he is I don't think he has
said he's made no comment one way I
don't know he did there was a lawsuit or
something some someone who's in a
relationship with somebody and he lied -
oh that was the year thinking of the
album confessions of a girl guy Dan like
you can't even see I think she goes out
even further if the picture wasn't
cropped reduce bigelow male gigolo I
never saw that the lines that are in
that Von Teese II what's her name
something Sharpton which I AK want a Z I
want Asian sharp it's always nice when
you have your weight in your name oh
yeah let me tell you so not a breast huh
right in the middle there oh my god what
a wacky body shape - not on round not
all the Sharpton's use the same workout
regimen no they don't know some of them
uh she's a bit wishy that play a couple
years ago she's probably grown what I'm
she wasn't small a couple years ago you
know why get your nails done at that
point my god I just don't want to feel
pretty now please and you know that's
just more cushion for the pushin so I'm
just some guys like a big girl I like
them things just not real change you
know she's beautiful
you like a big drug know you don't know
that's not for you been privy to a
couple in my day
how did you out yeah but I try to keep
that on the
yell I see as they say yeah yeah I'm not
something I wish I did but it's never
been my particular but you know it's all
something grab on to a lot of them are
very very grateful I don't need a skinny
girl I don't need to go be perfectly
sure I don't mind a sick girl with a big
ass or like a little extra I'm okay with
that but that's it that's too big I bet
quant Asia has a big ass yeah she does
want Asian even know how it's possible
that uh sure could penetrate that we
talking about
well she I mean she's a big girl I mean
he's a small guy
yeah but he's probably got he's right on
with with he probably packs a punch you
had a big dick I think I don't got a big
dick who knows whatever it is it know
you like like I don't know what what it
is it makes someone like a judge his mom
big look at my [ __ ] mother yes I think
that I think that's how you do seek out
people like your yeah is Raymond yeah I
don't know I mean it's just I can't
figure out why I fall in love like three
times during every live PDF assaut this
is any man that had blond and shorts and
a halter top that you're saying [ __ ]
like ready to just get engaged then that
you like that I love it nice little
skinny method well look it's never it's
never cost you any trouble before no oh
oh that's it what his mom's she's big
she was a like the woman did she she's
not as big but look she's monday she's a
little bigger
yeah sometimes but sometimes you you
know you gravitate like women who had
shitty dads [ __ ] hang out with me and
Anthony so quite a she showed up at an
usher show wearing a tiara because it
was her birthday you just need to know
something right yeah so she showed up
with a birthday queen tiara on and as
she's just enjoying you know you got it
bad a security guard comes up from
behind her and goes like you know I sure
would like to meet you all [ __ ] and then
she said you know they that whole thing
we've heard about wave guys go out there
yeah bring in the girls so she took the
pass and then and then she let it burn
he banged her nasty yeah did the nasty I
wish I do that keep mentioning ushered
right silent a comedian that would be so
nice to have that kind of path I sent
Kenny I tried to get a girl brought back
he come back nobody wants to come back
Jillian
she's got a handful of unaccepted
minutes yeah three neckbeard dudes
[ __ ] hang out yeah dude that thing
you did Thanks yeah great
hey Anna thanks for coming wind rain
coming back I don't know so much with or
that it isn't that that [ __ ] look
Terry a husband shitty lawyer
that's not gloria allred no but I think
she works for going Thank You Man
she does like a young Gloria oh yeah we
might sticking in her she is really
right down to that well she'd be lady
you don't get an arm you taking back
want Asia no want a you talk about
quantitation know what you recortes are
doing up there don't want say I love it
quant Asia what's that was she from
[ __ ] Asia or something
ah [ __ ] she's from Kwan made sense um
yeah you do chip at home yeah all the
time it makes me sigh can't stop doing
[ __ ]
Jenny think it would treat me and your
Anthony on his show on so I'll just does
chef exciting shows can't help it I it's
not even I want to do it I can't stop
doing the chip up it'd be great for
excess quantity and Troy started dating
yeah because then they could be Troy
quotation oh man that's a that's a great
couple name already perfect Troy is that
your speed a little bit big please take
her for a ride it's a tough one this
come on let her suck it quiet Asia would
work alright that's a little bit
different of a story but you know you
know it's funny though like a girl like
that I mean she's going to really work
hard for usher she's gonna pull out the
Balog and pony show but yeah sure they
all were quite far sure yeah sometimes
really hot girls just think that they
need to just kind of have it handed to
them but yeah gonna still going to put
in the ex go the extra mile yeah there's
gonna be like take that and run wind it
back she has an eye [ __ ]
Russia Russia uh sure story she does
like how the [ __ ] look at her she does
she tells all her girlfriends they said
one of the accusers is mail to a device
I use of us all yeah they said well uh
sure is not a confirmed by solid by any
stretch of imagination you're thinking
of Aaron Carter no I was at if it was
just because that they said one of the
accusers is somebody like I know yeah
they're one guy is saying that he
performed fellatio on Usher
he performed oral line okay but that's
again that's
just accusations my Raymond has not
commented on that she's going on some
money Aaron Carter Aaron Carter brought
a letter to his band which I don't know
who would have read that originally
Aaron Carter Aaron Carter he had a hit
song called Aaron's party he was like a
he was big like [ __ ] for 10 minutes
10 minutes would you let him - Tanya hug
[Laughter]
he was one of the Backstreet Boys
brother oh and he had his own career but
it was for like little kids
yeah like never really that's a good
career then he met his bisexual which I
thought was interesting because we had
just had a conversation about how like
anybody who's really relevant bisexual
is not a thing anymore you don't say
bisexual a mourner we fight sexual yeah
you say gender fluid you take Jennifer
that airflow binary the bestest gender
fluid jumping down your leg that means
it's coming out of your anus you're play
homosexual exactly is it bad to say
bisexual just comes across it so
outdated that really yeah Allard
yeah hey I'm by really old man your by
but you a that I hope I talk over myself
no I don't think I did do we have we got
that I can you rewind that Anthony I
want to hear him saying that Anthony
doesn't know how to do it you know he's
not there yet he's not he's not
Travis dogs pee oh no he's not a
greyhound which was a Travis dog so I
was just want to go check something with
Roland real quick okay he took a
masturbation break okay sometimes you
get the gun of big ready get your stuff
in their love workshop so take him on
with Travis does is he strokes his dick
onto a paper plate that he folds the
plate and he eats it oh it's gross oh
yeah yeah Aaron Carter is by he says I
guess something I do I knew his name I
just didn't know like what he had yeah
listen what's his song yeah Aaron party
Aaron's party hijack huh that's how I be
check that's a big air in town okay yeah
how long you're near Cardiff and grown
up now no that's how not so much
yeah look at this song music man it's
about the music the cue Aaron's party
Aaron's party yeah
oh wow this really is here for Aris
party it's a great it it was big - Alina
you like Aaron Carter yeah he just seems
like Aaron Carter was her first crush
now he just looks like a Heflin tactic
he's got a lot of trouble well years.i
song this is from like early 2000s
is he still popular he's not as popular
anymore no he did a run at doing The
Fantasticks off-broadway you know that
play that's in the short names activate
right next to the Duane Reade oh the one
that Gary Busey did oh yeah yeah Harry
Potter did that the longest-running show
at Broadway that's it or something um
came out in 2000 yeah do that Wow
yeah and now he's just very disheveled
he's very very drunk neck tats right he
does doesn't got a yeah that's fine for
men's hands to hold hold here we've got
like a bad skin that generally goes with
the little heroin addiction terrible
drugs was he doing drugs maybe who knows
boy who could ever know but he just
doesn't look what happened it was such a
cute guy used to be the flyest kid on
the block yeah yeah that fur coat I love
that video that was me
I had a fur coat as a child I want to go
to irons party you know yes I don't you
use the flyest kid on the block yes he
is I wanted to pet his little fur coat
okay look like a little like a little
kitty curled up in my lap oh she should
go home I want to go to the party now
he's all like an old man and I wonder
his life set now yeah I don't like him I
don't like him anymore
no wonder if that happen you know
there's that Hollywood and music scene
pedophilia ring that the Corey Feldman
talks about did he talk about that oh
yeah well he mentioned it right
talks too much about it they mentioned
that it's out there but no one ever
mentions names or anything Troy came to
the table with an article yesterday that
said Justin Bieber was calling out the
pedophiles yes but it was on one
conspiracy website and nothing no crime
reference what yeah you can't go with
those yeah yeah there's a lot of an eye
you don't know what's true was not yeah
Corey Feldman though is my new like I
cannot get enough of Corey Feldman the
new court the new Corey got his band the
Angels and every time so there's video
of him first he gets on a hoverboard it
was great because those are all the rage
now people love him still yeah yeah and
he's on the stage doing the robot on a
hoverboard [ __ ] on it and irony level
zero would you see him live if he could
in a second you would in a second I
would love anything get a couple drinks
in him [ __ ] you
well then he was singing and he basked
himself in the face with the microfiber
that and his tooth fell out
and then for 15-20 minutes everyone had
to look for Cortese - yeah and then the
last video did you see where the guy
puts the he's doing like a selfie video
and he's in the crowd and Corey's up
there he looks at the camera he eats a
banana yeah he's a banana he takes the
peel and throws it right of course he's
it's just trash waleed on stage yet
could we see that and then he puts it
back on himself but he's just there all
laugh Michael Jackson outfits a little
embarrassed my son of banana video this
is the tooth video not the banana just
embarrassing so embarrassing yeah this
is when the band by the way and the
angels are terrible music terrible yeah
they can't play a lick but they have to
sit there playing while he searches the
stage looking for his tooth that fell
out of his mouth and then uh can you
find it he did Herson in the crowd found
justice then handed it back to a quarry
Oh Corey I think I think he made oh come
out with a hit single before too long
yeah think I think so he's trying yeah
laying out he's always he's always out
of the road now yeah how he dresses
oh the Michael Jackson hair
oh I'm the dance you know he had he
showed up to Maria Menounos
and Keven memory and birthday percipient
yeah real and he showed up to Manning
they were kept in was trying to get him
to sing so much me I think he realized
that like I don't want to want to be
like it was yeah I don't wanna be
decoration here like hired help but then
they sang happy birthday to Kevin and
Kevin was like no and he turned on Corey
Feldman in the Angels and so if Corey
wouldn't sing to him he started singing
Corey's own music salaries a core it was
the greatest this Corey uncomfortable a
little but like you know it was in that
environment you kind of got to realize
like look this is a is a pretty cool
spot for you to be in yeah yeah you know
new I sing the [ __ ] song
do you think me did not but Kevin did
and Kevin Kevin at the time his life
what was there the song I think go for
it maybe the douchiest thing I don't
know it was it was it isn't it was it
was Corey felt it was ascension
millennium I love that one yeah favorite
Corey's box that's a little old Saint
John Mulaney yeah that doing this
Michael Jackson thing it's so [ __ ]
embarrassed attention millennium never
be real for it oh yeah oh yeah and who
knows in it also is uh what's his name
from Goonies mouth his mouth chunk no uh
the guy that was also in the Lord of the
Rings
Samwise Gamgee Samwise Gamgee Wow the
stairs when he comes down the stairs
going see how much Danny young by the
way I mean even cried Troy trying to
spell ascension my night on the I don't
know if he is God is hurting his brain
all right try it try ascension just try
to go going ice what's the word if I
mention Maleny have you ever heard the
word ascension before they have you or
no be honest uh maybe not to ascend okay
okay ASC okay no no album oh okay he's
trying to get that red outline out of
here but it's not work okay he wrote
Ascenta on a sentence a SCE thinks
tension is spelled a as centa
essentially I like how when you ask the
word ascension he brushed you off like
an idiot
right and then he spelled it eventually
one I have cen ta I said okay okay I
said yeah he's still working on it's a
tough one just google it
no he's still working on Ascension and
then you got to do millennium after that
oh my god which it was not okay he's not
doing good with millennium right now not
sure if it's the Double L I or II he's
got mi l will not got us a new mininum
right okay you've got a Raphael there no
you got really but I mean like God s io
n oh there's where the no no like I'm
new is look up videos I know you didn't
include news we mean that's what I did
that's the line Troy you just lie I love
it
we got to do that bit yeah okay we don't
realize what the video at the video to
the live version you so worked up with
speller narrative oh this isn't so bad
oh he cuts out of the [ __ ] bed he's
with a chick he was [ __ ] her all
night all right the Gion is very organic
oh yeah so tired from all the [ __ ]
that I did last night
Colin lovely just chick with all her
tits next to me Kevin likes the song I
love it love this cabin is it Keven
Undergaro xantham for life and he's such
some Michael tax and stuff and then does
yeah oh joy B does oh boy is it ever
Laurie in the shower just shirtless
looking like a shape Travis it has why
they have eyeliner on if you just got
out of the shower I thought eyeliner
dude that's what I look like
he's not even why did you just dry off
for the video why is this hair wet and
his body is bone dry
I don't know it's bone dry what does
this mean I don't know it's one shot so
this looks like [ __ ] bird Mesa girls
hot it is one shot false one shots off
they get that really close foreground
when they pass like a wall yeah and then
they stop and they all don't give away
Cory's tricks top like saw the angel
honey
hang on you Feeny Feeny yeah millennium
I can't wait for the car that's the best
part
now he's got a Michael Jackson clothes
on much much shorter than the girl oh
yeah this girls like Len glutamate look
at him right into the camera and now
sandwich Gamgee I think is at the bottom
of the stairs by the way do you like his
moves is in its douchey but might and
wise and got the goonies map it's mice
and Y's how did he call that favor and
huh well today the truth is not much
more thing I don't know why I don't know
what Samwise has been doing since Lord
of the Rings he's not exactly a lie that
is true it's been a while yeah I like
the light oh yeah that's another trick
by the way how did that light last yeah
now it's in his backyard he's like look
I got a black friend
haha look at it he likes his gloves in
his shirt I think it's cool it's so
embarrassing
he's got chicks though so I'm going to
be that embarrassed is he being ironic
no but look at his house it's like his
house but the backyard isn't very big
but did you notice that it's sponsored
neon energy drink anywhere what do you
think paid for this video here it is
Fanshawe Mulaney own here's a mean look
on his face yeah yeah he's putting that
like Michael Jackson look oh yeah I wish
it was the Michael Jackson look to the
head now he's deceased you yep now
there's a party going on in the house of
course where there's so many people
partying there they're not good but all
the hats oh no Michael Jackson hats
hanging from the ceiling so now they're
going to all do some Michael Jackson
dance it's like completely ripping off
Michael Jackson it's not cool though to
why all these people do it poorly well
it's cool
if Michael Jackson wouldn't mind Corey
Feldman ripping him off because he slept
with him you know man right wouldn't
anyone else get a C synthesis because
the estate even something after he's
dead but they're just like yes now let
him do whatever the [ __ ] he wants to so
embarrassing do you think this is
embarrassing
yes this is really this is look at it
all embarrassing that's ugly hottest
become bad chef yeah it's definitely not
just some hanger honor that he would
have chat is a professional who wants to
hang out a big fat chef I just
[Laughter]
now he's just hanging and watching a
flick yeah he wants to get away from the
party but look yeah hello Don yes they
already in his car sick now [ __ ] I hope
no one sees this dant yeah yeah yeah
then I can apply them here there you go
Jimmy
this is a brand grooving the grooving to
them bands loud oh those walls are
falling down special effects and all the
sudden needs in front of like a stadium
backdrop oh they're in a fake stadium
now wow it's cool it's green screamed in
a stadium that's good but it looks like
a green screen stated while he explained
would get back to the audience and when
I look the audience is not even the
right way why are your studio equipment
on stains
he's like Rupert Pupkin they're saved in
the back better dancing nobody's on it
how the walkie on thank you cool what oh
wow if you going back to bed I hope so
what a day
yeah this is a time warp yeah we're just
way too fancy I know and she uh-huh yeah
that works out nicely that Michael
Jackson's I was cool what Michael
Jackson something more Jenni yeah hm
Corey fellow self area by the intro
alright we could go from let's go crazy
let's go nuts to ascension millennium we
did supply aversions so yeah we want to
make you want to make let's go crazy
like just play out can I do a sense of
millennium and then that can play out
and then and then we'll be ready to
start the Cure start yeah yeah he was
the one that said that there was a big
pedophile ring corey feldman right other
other people are subscribed to me yeah I
hope not
will you care sure well I mean I'm fine
you want to those all say starlets or
stars and some I'm still waiting for the
Burt Reynolds when Burt Reynolds dies oh
my god yeah
what did he [ __ ] somebody on the couch
whatever yeah it's like supposedly
there's a lot of stories about Burt
Reynolds getting rails or something and
and giving head and everything in his
younger days trying to get into show
business and and there's a book already
written that was going to come out when
he dies oh my god that's the caveat on
the whole thing like he wrote the book
yes exposes everything
it's rumor you know but I I put it out
before he's dead where he's going to
look you know silly
who cares you're Burt Reynolds ya know
wants to picture uh you know the Bandit
yeah I don't call me oh yeah you see
that [ __ ] not Bandit [ __ ] for 700
miles ha ha ha and down mailboxes
driving through people's backyards
getting [ __ ] drivers drunk drivers
you men's backdoors daddy my pants came
off I hope both goddamn head with ya I
saw him on a clip recently and he looks
real bad does he like he went from being
kind of okay - just like frail ready to
yell over I was a 78
I would love to me I've never met Barack
I think is he use it a premiere a few
months ago and there yeah that's the one
I saw the clip he's like huh and I think
he did that just as like a favor for
whoever it was like yeah friends he's 81
Oh 81 they had him in the in one of the
Trans Am pedal car I'd like a Lang
at an Auto Show thing and he gets out
with the hat on he's just like everyone
else I got him now still full head of
hair though that's Wow he does look 81
oh yeah he looks thin like he looks
thinner than he had he's a gaunt they
call that then we have it on Stephen
King but I wonder is that because he's
sick or is that because his heart you
want to be tall they shrink and all this
father to be that stage probably abused
himself over the years I would think
I've abused myself - that photo of him
on that bearskin rug
that's for goddamn sure he doesn't drink
or he's a drinker right oh yeah throw
mankind all the people that he made the
smoke in the Bandit movies with and
Hooper 81 and the lawyer yards he [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah I mean like that yes they
did back then women and some men am i
right guys [ __ ] yeah Kitty's hairy
look at that photo the first row third
one in there's a gator that would be
fourth Troy you just counted ads for
when we do your numbers after we do the
spelling everyone look at look at that
look at that head of hair on him what
year is that that's finally in the
ladies I don't know it kind of looks 80s
he has not lost a strand huh yeah that
Adam what a healthy head of hair
earlier movies yesterday he had less he
seemed to be thinning I don't know how
that worked out for him but little team
along this yard mmm thank you have any
for hi Pat him pretty quickly yeah this
is that tough no that's no go up top
Celeste
yeah there huh look you know what that
must have been a windy day home over
thing gone that's awesome that quite
Gator I think was the one where he
really had like the comb-over thing
going is it amazing how different he
looks from 74 to 77 over smokey and
abandoned yeah definitely yeah because
he had that time without the mustache
for a while and then that's really did
deliverance we did deliver until you
have any mustache man that's us how good
is the [ __ ] longest shard that was an
unwanted she oh my god Syrena remake
better though I meet you I say this
stone cold drops an end bomb in the
remake oh yeah that's funny that is kind
of funny crew Eddie Albert was such a
piece of [ __ ] in that one oh yeah shoot
him
great [ __ ] ending to a movie yeah
you seriously it there's no i watch the
remake oh yah his original not
originally really great
see look can channel your real hair
taker this is my buddy Chris Rock we
means that supposed to be a superior
don't tear taster no I know it's a
romaine thank you
take it like it's also an abstainer
didn't start with Richard he'll Thunder
Richard Kiel yeah I think I broke his
[ __ ] neck yeah Richard Kiel was a
anytime you needed a giant freak back
then was that jaws
yes was that the guy from happy gilmore
and you can count on me waiting for you
in the parking lot how did he has such a
long illustrious career being like that
usually they die off when they're like
yeah five years old or something yeah
how big was he he was sick seven or
something pretty [ __ ] tall anything
for you mr Gilmore Haley Adela radio
legend just look in whoo oh it's Dennis
Oh
does any add any dip in the old hair guy
oh yeah yep I mean Danny is just like a
go to Vuitton Suhag yeah I don't think
so he does it at home super classy yeah
let's take em nice and [ __ ] walk like
it's so yeah you get super cuts in a
home pitch here Jeff here roll our own
says he's coming
I see rolling tour saw can't up food in
front of me during that super cuts and
just for men we're gonna see Jeff next
to answer make Danny a handsome boy this
away David Eggers doing something else
for okay I was molested and passed
around Corey Feldman describes ordeal at
the handler okay let's make sure that we
have that no that's not just I'm saying
I don't worry about it we're good eleven
years only his first rape to Jesus
Christ oh geez
he said he was molested repeatedly by
men why isn't he naming any names though
this is where these guys what are you
protecting these [ __ ] pedophiles okay
say the name it was Bill Corey Birdman
name names yeah they even have things
anymore they falsely
they always say that things happen but
no no one needs a name our 'full yeah I
mean say who it is get them in trouble
right you had to get them in trouble
what's the worst they could do put them
back in show business
hey what's up just go ahead entertained
a chip off in practicing chip looks
petrified I thought he was right behind
me he will be yeah yeah it's Mike's
chance why I don't know